there are no ruining Anna Wintour's
Fashion Week by bringing in a screaming
baby if she wanted to hear crying
children while admiring new clothes
she'd go to the factories where they saw
them they'll stop giving the job of
fashion designer to the wrong person can
you guess which of these two men is now
the hottest designer in America
is it the one in the nice tux no it's
the one in the purple velvet pantsuit
and baby booties now where have I seen
that look before never oh now that those
two guys who climbed that mile-high rock
wall are down and the hottest thing in
sports is the Tough Mudder an obstacle
course where competitors carry 200-pound
logs swim in ice water dodge live
electrical wires and crawl through pipes
full of mud someone just explained to me
what is wrong with white people the role
of Google autocomplete really reflects
popular questions previous users have
asked and when you type is the moon it
adds real
give me the black capsule then I give up
because that means the most frequent
question people ask Google about the
moon is is it real also if people have
really asked is the moon Hollow is the
Mona spaceship and is the Mona hologram
and president Rick Perry it's all your
doesn't believe in evolution new role
the nose-to-nose faceoff at the boxing
weigh-in must be recognized as the most
homoerotic moment in all of life fellas
you're buff you're in your underwear
you're a centimeter away from making out
and you keep calling each other [ __ ] at
this point it would actually less gay if
you put the other guy's penis in your
mouth